it has begun war is coming so why are
you here to save all people you know
what we found you know when we were when
we're describing what the film should be
is that the most sensible thing is to go
back to the very beginning the first
realtime strategy game which was called
orcs and humans and it's about that
initial first contact moment not knowing
about each other at all to begin with
and then meeting for the first time and
that really gives us the opportunity to
explain who they are from each other's
perspectives Peter Jackson and Lord of
the Rings first trilogy really kind of
set the bar and the expectations of what
a fantasy film should be and how it
should look and we needed to match that
level but in some way give it its own
identity and it's in its own look
fortunately Warcraft by its very nature
you know the artwork of Blizzard it has
a very signature style so the challenge
was really was to was to take that
signature style and find a way to make
it work in a live-action environment we
knew that we wanted to try and have a
basis in reality as much as possible
even though it was a fantastical
environment and fantastical characters
we would have photographic references
for everything and I think the teams at
ILM really appreciated that and it and
it benefited them as far as being able
to see what as much as possible actually
look like within the lighting conditions
and within the environments that they
were being shot in I think what we
wanted to do is as a fan of the game
myself and as a player is can we make a
film which will communicate to an
audience that doesn't know anything
about this world and why people felt so
passionate about it and then obviously
for the fans of the game can we make a
film where they feel like they've gone
home they do they do they recognize it
and that was really the approach for
Azeroth I'll give you that
you